grenoble qui fut une ville de beaucoup
de malheurs qui fut l'aide et militaires
longtemps placé sur le chemin des
invasions souffrit des querelles de
l'histoire on ne sait pas où le passé
ces réfugiés les vieilles maisons
disparaissent tout grenoble et d'omaha
des constructeurs qui discutent répètent
les mots de la foi en l'avenir font des
calculs avec une sorte de frénésie
cependant deux mille ans d'histoire vont
ils s'effacent et sous la marche
triomphale des pelleteuses et
excavatrices
alors nous sommes partis à la recherche
du passé monsieur à vesoul va-t-on
préserver les vieux quartiers de
grenoble dont beaucoup d'aspects reste
encore méconnue il ya certainement des
mesures à prendre pour préserver dans
les vieux quartiers de grenoble les
édifices qui méritent d'être conservés
il ne s'agit pas de tout garder mais je
pense qu'il faudrait dresser un
inventaire préalable des richesses
archéologiques du quartier saint laurent
du quartier notre-dame même du quartier
très cloître il serait vraiment dommage
qu'on opère dans les années à venir un
ratissage complet de ces quartiers qui
constitue le grenoble primitif le
grenoble groupe est déjà depuis près de
deux mille ans à l'intérieur de
l'enceinte romaine
il n'existe plus tellement
de richesse monumental dans notre ville
il faut préserver ce qui subsiste éviter
des destructions y réfléchit il est
assez regrettable qu'on n'ait pas
conservé une plus grande partie du
rempart romain qui a été mis à jour il
ya quelques années lors de la percée de
la rue de la république les y aura-t-il
un comité et on en parle on en parle je
pense que d'ici peu se constituera un
groupement des amis du vieux grenoble
tout disposé à épauler l'action de la
municipalité et ce comité se composerait
de personnes connaissant parfaitement
les ressources monumentale de ses vieux
quartiers de personnes éclairées et
qui pourrait donner des conseils utiles
et qui j'en suis certain
agirait sans aucune passion et sans
attacher plus d'importance qu'il n'en
faut à certains souvenirs qui peuvent
disparaître tandis que d'autre part on
insisterait sur la nécessité de rajeunir
de rabat les certaines façades procéder
à une opération de de curetage nettoyage
des anciennes maisons comme on l'a fait
dans d'autres villes comme on le fait à
lyon dans le quartier mercier r comme on
le fait à paris dans le quartier du
marais il ya là des les exemples
extrêmement intéressants à suivre
voilà me rivière sestier vous êtes
présidente d'honneur de la société
dauphinoise d'ethnologie et
d'archéologie parfaitement actuellement
nous sommes dans une maison au coeur du
vieux grenoble à lesparre oui si ça vous
n'êtes absolument au coeur même du
grenoble puisque vous êtes à l'angle de
la voie romaine la via média qui
empruntaient le trajet actuel de la rue
brocherie la voie romaine arrivée par la
forte qui est situé à l'angle de la
place notre dame la rue de la route
romaine à voie romaine venait de vienne
suivez les hauteurs de chalut on descend
d emprunter la via média est allé
rejoindre la rue de la république actuel
n'est ce pas de la grand rue pour
arriver à la porte
romaine là c'était la porte viennoise et
toutes les maisons qui nous entourent
date depuis combien de temps lyon ces
maisons sont très anciennes on ne peut
pas dire exactement les façades ont été
ravalées on ne se rend pas compte mais
si on entre dans les cours on voit le
siècle où la maison a été construite
vous en avez du 15e et du 16e c'est
facile à voir la maison du xvème les
accolades le coeur même du grenoble
l'heure actuelle c'est ce qui est dans
les neuf hectares qui étaient enserrés
dans les l'enceinte romaine qui a été
construite au xiiie siècle
mais toutes ces raisons
le riz servent elles ont toutes ces
charmantes les unes que les autres et
c'est ce qui fait le pittoresque d'une
ville et qui révèle son âme
c'est pour ça que les vieilles maisons
sont beaucoup plus cher à tous les
amants du passé que les maisons modernes
actuels évidemment et bien la maison
nous trouvons actuellement et une maison
qui date d'avant la révolution du reste
sur la porte vous rêviez de numérotage
révolutionnaire à ce moment là on a
changé le nom des rues et on a changé
les numéros est bien le numéro pied sur
notre maison est le seul à grenoble 10
soit encore existants y en avait un
autre usager on a enlevé dans cette
maison il y a une très jolie histoire
c'est un mariage clandestins qui s'est
fait un laitage même où nous sommes
c'était la file de l'apothicaire d'alors
breton qui a refusé un sylvie leur union
a été bénie par un prêtre qui n'avait
pas prêté serment